foreign
good evening councilors ladies and
gentlemen and I welcome you to this
meeting of the council
one would normally invite one's chaplain
to say a few words but as there is such
a small amount of business and not such
that it's of I suppose moral compass
I've let the Revenant heal off this
evening so that he can continue his
preparations for the forthcoming festive
season so please be seated
um
I would however I'll remain standing
just for a moment I would however just
like to make a few words very few words
that as we approach the season of Good
Will to all perhaps we might all
remember that it doesn't matter which
party we represent or which party a
resident might support or whether
they've ever voted at all
that we are elected each of us to
represent and serve each and every one
of our residents to the very best of our
ability that's my comment for this
evening thank you
the first item is apologies and I've
received apologies for absence from
councilors Bennett dagnell
Gilbert and Myers can I ask if anyone is
aware of any other apologies
councilor Denise Western Union Council
councilor White
councilor Proctor Council Shirley
Proctor Council Shirley Proctor
councilor Ross councilor James Wright
councilor James Wright someone over
there councilor shanky Z
yeah did you have an apology
are there any further apologies to be
noted
right thank you one and door
um
voting and broadcast information you'll
note that we have some new technical
equipment in the chamber this evening
and on your desk
before you should be individual units
with a microphone and an interface for
voting
I am assured the microphones are working
by pressing the bar on and off up to a
maximum of three
be switched on at a time
however we will have to wait for the
full installation to be completed before
we can use the voting system
um apparently that is coming from
Germany and should be with us for the
next meeting in January
until then in the event of requiring a
vote I will ask for a show of hands
should a vote be necessary certainly
this evening
the meeting is also being streamed live
on the council's committee meetings
YouTube channel the whole of the meeting
will be recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt items and this
activity promotes Democratic engagement
in accordance with section 100 a
brackets nine close brackets of the
Local Government Act
1972. thank you
foreign
won the minutes the first item is
minutes and I move at the minutes of the
meeting held on 12th of October 2022 be
taken as read and signed as a correct
record is that second second itcher all
in favor
thank you
item two announcements it is with some
regret that I refer to the sad death of
a former colleague Mrs Dora Carter aged
99 years on the 23rd of October
Mrs Carter whose funeral service was on
the 7th of November was also a former GM
counselor and served for many years on
the police committee as a mark of
respect by the council please can we
stand for a few moments in memory of our
former colleague
thank you everybody for that Mark of
respect to someone who clearly had a
remarkable longevity of life
does the leader of council wish to make
any announcements this evening
as tempting as it is chair to use the
platform tonight of all nights
um no thank you thank you do the chairs
of the scrutiny committees have anything
to announce on behalf of their
committees councilor Acton
yes just briefly
um scrutiny budget scrutiny sessions
there's two sessions one on the 29th and
one on the 1st of December and all
members non-executive members are
welcome to come along to those two
sessions okay thank you
thank you councilor Acton for that
encouragement to all
councilor wetton
just briefly to say that um due to
events we have lost one of the health
scrutiny meetings
um but we're going doing our best to
find a new date for it rather than lose
that slot altogether
and
um there is still a lot of
activity going on around trying to get
the altering a minor injuries unit
reopened
if anything the position probably is
worse than the last time I addressed
this Council but it doesn't
stop the committee's determination to uh
to get the important unit reopened as
soon as possible
and two task and finish
projects are underway and I think they
will provide important
um
important results for for this Council
and I look forward to being able to
present those results in due course
thank you
thank you councilor wetton uh councilor
Denise Weston
um should have had a cyp
um scrutiny committee yesterday we are
in the process of organizing
um a further date possibly in January or
February and um
along with counselorette and I too am
involved in um two task and finish
groups as are some of my members thank
you thank you very much
item three is membership of committees
and other bodies
and I've got a strange scripture item
four and listed on the summons are
several changes to the composition of
committees and other bodies which are
being reported to council for
information
such as they are on your papers can they
be noted please
okay
I turn the page to item four local
Authority review of polling districts
and polling places the main item of
business this evening is a report of the
returning officer on a review of the
boroughs polling districts and places
before the council is a report with
appendices setting out the
recommendations and ask members to note
that a slight revision is now proposed
in respect of the temporary North
polling District
consequently appendices A and B have
been updated and published with the
agenda papers
with that change please can I ask
councilor Ross the executive member for
finance and governance to introduce and
move the report councilor Ross please
thank you Matt this work has been
informed by the local government
boundary review set to come into Force
for the local elections in May
2023. Awards in Trafford have been
affected apart from Brooklyn's Brooklyn
St Martin's and Ashton upon mersey and a
key priority for for the review
including the accessibility of polling
stations was to ensure that our polling
districts are identifiable and
understandable and correspond correctly
with their parliamentary constituencies
appendix B is helpful in showing what
the new polling districts look like and
the locations of the polling stations
within them
there was a consultation over the summer
and the results of that consultation are
set out in appendix d
we intend to have a communication plan
to explain any changes and we'll write
out to electors where there has been a
change to their polling district and
polling station arrangements and I'd
like to draw your attention to section
4.5 to 4.10 of the report that sets out
our approach to the use of schools as
polling stations in conclusion I'm
asking colleagues to note and agree the
recommendations one to five in the
report thank you mayor
is that seconded please second nature
do any members wish to speak on this
report
final answer
sorry right councilor Brophy
um it's just an observation about broad
Heath Ward although it doesn't impact on
our world I feel compelled to mention it
because in the report it puts a bit of
um broad Heath in timberley North that
isn't there
in the broad Heath ward in the report
I'll tell you what page it is if you
like
so it's page six of 46.
and it says
lost part of one bhe to timpley North
and that's not actually happening
foreign
which page of this report do you
actually you mentioned broad Heath Ward
and I'm looking for the page page
the report I'm on the revised part I
know it's been corrected for timpley
North
they've taken
vhe
whilst
put into timpley North
um but it's still in Broad Heath as a
loss rather than a no change
yeah leader thank you
if I can shed some light chair I think
the report is slightly
um inaccurate in that there has been a
typing error on the grid page of the
broad Heath
polling stations so simply to note that
the loss is bhf lost to templey North
Ward and that bhe remains in its
entirety
in Broad Heath Ward with its current
polling station remaining unchanged
which is Park Road Academy on freeston
Road
in timperley so there does need to be a
small revision to that but in terms of
what members would be supporting tonight
the future broad Heath Ward would have
unchanged BHA b d and e a small revision
to take in around 100 electors in bhc
from the Saint Mary's Ward around Alton
Road Ashley Drive one to five Midway and
20 houses on Woodhouse Lane and that is
how the report should read thank you
thank you thank you leader for those who
are trying to follow that and the lead
has done an extremely good job in
explaining that I have to say uh is
actually on page 32 of my papers and
he's pretty much word perfect as if he'd
learned the whole of this from beginning
to end every page so with that
clarification I hope councilor Brophy
um I think as the leader says we can
accept that that minor Amendment will
take place to the papers effectively
before enactment if that's the right
word are there any other counselors or
members who wish to ask questions or
make comment
um I think there's probably not much for
councilor Ross to respond to at this
point shaking his head in which case
um can I ask that the report now having
been moved and seconded can it be agreed
please
thank you
um that then is the end of the meeting
and I thank you for your attendance
again once again there is members there
is an open invitation to join me in the
Parlor for refreshments and I hope if I
don't see you then you enjoy the rest of
the evening and enjoy the the coming
seasonal period and one final thing to
say is you'll be aware I have been
appealing for the members to come
forward with
individuals who serve the elderly or
serve the young people in our Borough
with a view to or have served them for
some time and do a very good job and
many do with a view to them being
invited to a Civic reception
I just urge you to send me some more uh
recommendations please and dare I say it
particularly from the gentleman members
amongst us thank you and good evening to
you all thank you